unredacted records obtained by the
nation and The Intercept reveal new
details about the possible origins of
covid the documents show the Great Links
that Dr Anthony fauci and the National
Institute Institutes of Health
apparently went to to rule out the lab
League Theory let's bring in Fox News
medical contributor Dr Mark Siegel so
The Intercept obtained unredacted email
exchanges that involved Dr fauci and Dr
Francis Collins the head of the NIH
here's what The Intercept said in part
quote the documents show that in the
early days of the pandemic fauci and
Collins took part in a series of email
exchanges and telephone calls in which
several leading virologists expressed
concern that SARS cov2 looked
potentially quote engineered the
participants also contemplated the
possibility that laboratory activities
had inadvertently led to the creation
and release of the virus the
conversations apparently dot conveyed an
anxious urgency what more do we know
about this
you know John this is actually a
surprise to me now Jimmy Tobias who
wrote about this for the nation that's
an ultra left publication so you can see
that it's starting to raise eyebrows on
both sides of the aisle that's number
one number two I'm surprised about that
email that I saw there from fauci who
says basically what is this furring
cleavage site doing here and that
cleavage site is what Dr Robert Redfield
has raised all the questions about in
other words it allows the virus to
attach more easily to human cells and it
is not usually found in a bad
coronavirus what's it doing there what
are some of the other sequences around
doing there and there was a big stir
over this apparently internally and
Christian Anderson from Scripps in La
was involved in this now I've
interviewed him as well on this and he
said that over time looking at different
versions and seeing the fully published
version of the virus he was pretty sure
that it came from nature but here's the
point a narrative emerged from NIH and
that narrative was this came from nature
I have interviewed fauci multiple times
from this I'm convinced he thinks it
came from nature but the problem is that
the other possibility was never given
full air to breathe and as time has gone
on John as you know they haven't found
an intermediate creature which which is
where it would go from a bad coronavirus
doesn't just go from a bad coronavirus
to man and they've never answered the
question about that furrying cleavage
site one more Point Redfield says how
did this virus suddenly spread
asymptomatically to millions and
millions of humans overnight and Peter
polisi at Mount Sinai who's probably the
world's best expert at this he paused
when I asked him that he says it doesn't
do that so yeah wet Market involved but
lab looks pretty suspicious right now
yeah you know some scientists were
actively entertaining the idea that if
it didn't come from a lab if it wasn't
engineered maybe it did emerge from a
lab somehow through animal animal
experiment something called serial
passage which is a type of gain of
function research some scientists
thought that they'd found the answer
when they noticed that pangolins these
weird looking creatures that kind of
look a little like armadillos with
dragon armor on them were showing up
with SARS cov2 but it didn't include
that Farine cleavage site that you just
talked about but there did seem to be an
effort here an all-out effort to
disprove the lab leak Theory instead of
science normally does saying well here's
a possibility on this hand and here's
the possibility on this hand and we
don't really know which one is true it
was kind of like well this one is
worrisome enough but this one's really
scary so let's get rid of it before it
gains any traction why would they do
that
well I can tell you why because they are
committed to what's called an
international Consortium of scientists
and the law Obama was trying to actually
push back on gain of function research
and really was worried about it but
under the current law for emerging for
enhanced potential pandemic pathogens as
long as it's under strict supervision
you can do it the problem is how much of
a strict supervision do we have in the
Netherlands how much do we have in China
and by the way how much do we even have
in North Carolina where this work is
going on so I don't think the NIH really
wants to admit that the genie got out of
the bottle whether it caused this
pandemic or not because it's going
around on around the world you could be
a scientist John in China but the but
the Chinese Communist party is looking
over your shoulder there yeah and it's
certainly suppressing anything that
you're doing in terms of sharing
information of what's really going on
speaking to what's really going on are
We doc ever going going to really know
where this thing came from
we should have had boots on the ground
in China at the beginning I think even
boots on the ground now would help I
think we need what you just called for
today open disclosure we might be able
to figure this out if scientists
admitted what was going on you know we
should have a look inside these Labs we
should know what's going on and one more
thing a major journal a major study came
out of Japan and the UK in the summer
and basically said in the meantime you
know we shouldn't be doing these
experiments that probe and push viruses
to see where they can go we can figure
out treatments and vaccines without that
I think a moratorium is called for while
we figure this out but we still can
figure this out all right let's hope we
do doc always good to catch up with you
thank you
great to be on with you John thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else